[Music]
today I'm gonna be talking about Android
memory and specifically Android memory
and games from a games perspective my
name is Bill villedieu and I work with
game developers I'm a developer advocate
and working with game developers often
times I hear things about memory
problems that they have running out of
memory so I want to talk about some of
the things about memory and Android but
specifically about one of the things I
first want to mention before I go into
that is there have been some
improvements in Q with respect to memory
so during my slides I'm gonna be showing
this Q logo and that will kind of help
you remember that this is a new
something new and cute all right so what
are some of the problems that developers
face with memory the biggest problem is
of course running out of memory and
having your game just crash now Android
is different than other platforms if you
take for example consoles you have a
fixed amount of memory and it's much
easier to predict how much memory you
can use and how much memory to budget
for in the case of the PC you have a lot
of swap space so if you start running
low on memory you know a lot of that
memory can be swapped to disk however in
the case of Android when it runs low on
memory about the only thing that happens
it can happen to you that it can do
about it is your game gets killed okay
so it's not not not good so you want to
avoid that situation and I'm gonna be
talking about that today how to avoid
that now
ideally game developers would like to
have fixed memory budgets it makes it
much easier when you're developing the
game you know we tell your artists I
have a certain amount for textures
geometry you know you can set aside a
certain amount for code but in order to
do this you need to know how big that
whole pie is and and that's the hard
thing to do because in order to do this
you need to know the size of memory how
much memory is available so in the case
of Android you can set one one answer to
this question is as much as possible but
that's still kind of vague because it
depends a lot on the system you know the
system can't be taken out of memory it
still has to be there so your game has
to share that memory with with the
system so what this means is there's
really no definite fixed size on how
much available memory you have I'm
hoping that by seeing this talk and
learning more about Android memory and
understanding how it works that you'll
be able to prevent the bad things from
happening like crashes now before it
gone I did this memory test I put
together this little app that allocates
memory and every time you press on this
red button and allocates a hundred
megabytes and I was able to allocate 4.1
gigabytes on a device that only has four
gigabytes of RAM how is that possible so
first of all I don't recommend that
games do this it's you're gonna run into
other problems if you try to allocate
that much memory but I want you to think
about that and we'll come back to that
later
so here are some of the things that I
think game developers should know about
Android memory first of all the Android
memory philosophy it's similar to Linux
because Android is based on Linux it
wants to use all of RAM if you think
about it
free RAM is really doing no one any good
it's just sitting there doing nothing
so the way Android uses the all of this
Ram is to keep apps in memory the result
of this is you've never really have a
lot of free memory on Android devices so
why do you keep all of these apps in
memory is so you can do things like fast
app switching if you have an app that
you started and you put it in the
background and you go to another app
you're able to switch to different apps
because they stay resident in memory now
the nice thing about queue a new
improvement in queue is that we're doing
very active compaction of these
background apps so that if you have a
very large app like your game for
example you can actually put your game
into the background the users can put
your game into the background and it'll
still be resident and running when it
comes back so let's look at some of the
specifics about device memory there's
different types of memory you can
categorize them by size and also by how
fast that memory is so for example RAM
is the fast memory it's limited in size
it's smaller than other types of memory
one thing to consider about RAM is that
it's shared between the CPU and the GPU
so they both are using that memory
Android devices also have secondary
storage right this is where your apps
are stored when they're not being used
this is non-volatile Ram it's slower
than Ram
and but you have a lot more of it so
this diagram really isn't to scale
another type of RAM that I want to
mention or memory that I might want to
mention is Z RAM and this is compressed
memory that the system set aside sets
aside for swapping so go into a little
bit more detail here what are the
different types of memory obviously we
have three memory three free memory
pages we also have pages that are
storage back so this is these are pages
that are stored on that storage the
secondary storage device and also are in
memory note I just want to point out
when I say memory
I'm usually referring to RAM so I'm
using those terms interchangeably when I
talk about storage memory I'll usually
try to refer to it as storage
now there's also clean pages clean pages
or pages that are storage back but have
not been modified and you also have
dirty pages which pages that have been
modified anonymous memory you might have
heard about that
that's memory that you're allocating
that you allocate through malloc so what
happens when you run low on memory on
Android first of all there's something
in a kernel called kernel swap demon or
K swap D and this is responsible for
reclaiming memory so it turns pages that
are used in to free memory it does this
by swapping pages or in some cases
deleting the pages the interesting thing
is it runs asynchronously from your game
so here's an example where we've got a
storage back page it's clean we'll say
is clean not modified and it's this pink
rectangle here and let's say we want to
reclaim this memory so what K swap D
does is it just deletes the page right
because it hasn't been modified if
needs it again it'll just read it in
from storage suppose you have modified
memory and even if it was storage back
you couldn't just delete it because it
would it would that those changes would
be lost
so what Android can do is swap it into Z
room so that partition of memory that's
used for compressed memory now because
it's compressed it's going to take up
less space so this is a good thing
Android keeps track of certain memory
thresholds both low memory thresholds
and high memory thresholds and it uses
these thresholds as triggers on when to
do reclaims here's an example of how K
swap D reclaims memory say your
application is allocating memory and
this blue line here is the amount of
free memory that you have so as you keep
allocating memory over time that blue
line goes down until it eventually hits
the low memory threshold at that point K
swap D kicks in and starts reclaiming
pages so your memory your free memory
goes back up but you don't want to keep
reclaiming page pages you know because
some of those pages you want to keep in
memory because your your game might need
them so it stops for claiming memory and
then if your game keeps reclaim it if
your game keeps allocating memory this
whole process is gonna repeat itself I
also want to introduce this concept here
of available RAM versus free RAM so I
consider available RAM to be the free
RAM plus any kind of RAM that can be
reclaimed by case floppy so another part
of the kernel that helps to free up
memory is something called low memory
killer and it's also called LMK
abbreviated LMK and for each process it
keeps track of an out of memory adjust
score and a score ranges from minus one
thousand to one
mm to higher the score the more likely
to get killed so those get those with a
score of a thousand get killed first the
ones at the bottom at minus 1,000 a very
low score and are highly unlikely to get
killed so the background apps have these
high scores so they're more likely
they're the first ones to get killed
your foreground app is going to get
killed if it has to get killed
after all the background apps and this
system is almost never gonna get killed
so all of these system processes you
know they're not going to get killed
before your game one thing to consider
is that om can modify the behavior of
low memory killer so it can vary from
different devices there's an example of
how low memory killer works with a game
so you have your game here running in a
foreground and it has a out of memory
adjust score of zero and you have these
other two apps in the background and
they have out of memory of score of nine
oh five and nine hundred
on the right here is a little chart
showing the available memory and we'll
see what happens when your game starts
allocating memory
okay so you've allocated memory below
this 9:05 threshold the core it's a
memory threshold corresponding to the
out of memory just score at that point
low memory killer knows that it can kill
that process and because of that it
frees up memory okay this is great so
your app just keeps on allocating memory
eventually it'll get to the point where
it hits this threshold and now the
Chrome App in the background will get
killed by low memory killer if your game
keeps allocating it'll it'll eventually
get to the point where well sorry it
gets more memory back because it killed
a chrome but it'll eventually get to the
point where it gets below that
zero thresholds and at that point low
memory killer will come in and kill your
your game so that's how games get killed
because they run low on memory Android
knows that it has to keep a certain
amount of free memory around and it'll
even kill your game to make sure that
that amount of free memory is available
fortunately Android does have something
called on term memory on term memory is
a warning about low memory that your the
system is running low on memory and it's
a callback to your game to tell it to do
something now in Android P and earlier
versions it's it wasn't that reliable
they were problems where it was not
signaling this on trend memory even
though you're in a critical stage where
you're going to get killed so games or
apps may not have been paying attention
to this now this has been improved in
queue and it's using a new trigger now -
oh let the on term memory know when to
send its call went to the system to send
this on to memory call it's called
pressure stall information pressure
stall information was something
introduced in Linux and it was modified
by Android to measure the the time it
takes to obtain memory so if you
remember I was talking about case floppy
and low memory killer these things take
time and so as the system runs low on
memory these take more time to reclaim
memory and give the app more memory so
pressure stall information measures that
and the longer it takes when it gets to
a certain point it'll say ok now I'm
gonna warn the app that we're really
running low on memory
and that's where an aunt rumor gets
called so I just want to kind of
summarize here you've got low memory
killer case flop D and then you have
your game and these are all these are
running asynchronously and the problem
with that is things tend to happen
unexpected
fortunately changes in queue like
pressure stall information should help
with this so what things should your
game do to avoid low memory situations
the first thing is respond to long term
memory now we feel that this is more
reliable
it provides reliable signals so it's
something you really should respond to
because it's probably the only warning
you're gonna get now entree memory still
has high latency so it could you could
be running into a critical situation and
it may take some time for entre memory
to notify your game so when you do get
it you want to make sure you take action
and I mean doing things like trying to
reduce the allocations you know slow
down your allocations try to remove
things from memory as possible maybe if
you've got a lot of shaders resident in
memory you want to evict some of those
shaders maybe you want to use lower res
textures things like that and also
because you're running in a low memory
situation you have a greater probability
that the game might get killed so at
this point you might want to consider
saving the state of the game so if it
does get killed at least you know the
players were playing this game are not
going to be so frustrated when the game
gets launched again and they haven't
lost lost much
so here's some Java code that shows how
you can use on term memory so in a main
activity what you can do is make sure
you implement components callback - and
then you just implement this on term
memory call and notice that on term
memory gets passed a level and this
level corresponds to the severity of the
memory situation so it can be either
moderate or low and critical which is
the last one there are a few other
levels but these are the ones I think
are important once I've looked at and in
my case the only thing I did was here is
pop up a message showing what the memory
level is but in your case what you would
want to do is actually take actions and
try to reduce the memory so for unity
developers here's an example of a
c-sharp script and there's something
called application low memory events in
unity and these correspond to on term
memory calls so you want to subscribe to
this event and then have a callback that
gets called when this event happens so
unity does have this resource unload
call what you can make that's one
possible thing you can do to reduce the
memory pressure so another thing that
games should do and in most games do
this typically it's just to be
conservative about their memory budgets
what things should you consider well you
should take into account the physical
RAM size and also you want to look at
how much typically does the operating
system and system processes use in this
case it's about one and a half gigabytes
and it's on a 4 gigabyte device these
can vary over times or remember I was
saying you don't have definite amounts
for these so that's where you want to be
conservative
and you also want to look at the maximum
amount of Z RAM size so as I mentioned Z
Ram is something is used as compressed
memory it's used for swapping when
memory gets low so the more Z Ram that
you can have the better your device will
be able to handle low memory situations
how do you tell how much Z room you have
well if you look in the proc mem info
file you can see the swap total is shown
here and that's the the max amount of Z
Ram your device can have so in this case
it's about a gigabyte if we look at some
typical games this is like kind of a
random sampling of games on a 4 gigabyte
device the most that these games
allocate these are peak memory usage is
only about one point two three gigabytes
so they're really not pushing the amount
of physical memory up to the limit of
physical memory very much now if you
can't be really conservative the other
thing is you should be flexible so this
means you need to be more dynamic with
the memory instead of fixed of course
this means you're going to need to
respond to those on term memory calls
and because you're now taking into
account low memory situations and and
hitting up against that limit you need
to do more game memory management and
really design your game to have a
variable amount of memory now beat
crashing when you run out of memory
isn't the only thing that can happen so
at some point when you have lots of
memory and everything's working fine and
the point when you crash because he ran
out of memory you could hit thrashing
and thrashing is when you have just
continuous swapping this main symptom of
it is you have very long delays frames
could take seconds to execute
then basically the only thing you can do
about that is reduce the working set of
your game you know reduce the memory
footprint of it so here's an example of
how to look for thrashing we have this
tool called systrace hopefully you've
used it and I've seen it before is part
of the Android SDK and if you notice
here it shows processes being executed
on the CPU cores and you notice this one
core is just continuously using
executing K swap D K swap do you
remember is the one that does the
swapping it reclaims memory so when you
see it active that much it's you should
be suspicious the other thing to look
for is your processes are getting into a
state where they're blocked on i/o
because these pages
remember these memory back paid storage
back pages have been deleted so it needs
to they need to read them back into
memory when executing all right another
tip don't try to don't allocate too much
too fast so the speed of allocations
can actually matter when you get into
really sensitive low memory situations
as I mentioned reclaiming memory takes
time so you don't want to your
allocations to outpace how fast you can
reclaim memory and the result of this
the game gets killed gets killed
potentially sooner than it it really
needs to get killed
now I'm going to talk about some of the
tools that we have for for debugging and
for profiling native memory and I just
turn native here of course because we're
look talking about games and these are
this is memory that's allocated by C++
as opposed to like the Java heap so one
of the tools you can use is a kind of a
class of tools mem info and these are
just memory statistics
so they include things like adb shell
dumps this mem info right and that gives
you some statistics on memory and
similarly there's something called debug
memory info which gives you basically
the same information problem is it slow
and the reason why is collecting what's
called PSS storage and another problem
is it's not always consistent
it takes an it gathers information say
of graphics memory and graphics memory
is collected by the GPU driver which is
something Android really doesn't have
control over and it's differs it's
different with different GPU vendors
they not they may be reporting memory
differently than another vendor does or
they may even be reporting at different
depending on the version of the driver
so here's an example of what you would
see with dumps this amendment foe
obviously it shows the Java heap which
usually isn't a big part of a game
because it uses native memory the native
heap is is probably where most of your
memory allocations are going to be
coming from and also the graphics memory
because games do a lot of graphics and
it gives you the total here and I
mentioned before it's slow because it's
using PSS the other type of memory is
called RSS so what's the difference
between PSS and RSS so PSS is
proportional set size so it includes the
private memory that your game is using
and it also includes the shared memory
so if different processes are sharing
some of that memory that you're using
it'll include that but it'll measure it
proportionally based on how many
processes are sharing that memory RSS is
much simpler it's just the total pages
that your game is using
we think that RSS is probably more
useful for games one of the reasons this
is much easier to collect that
information it's faster the other reason
is it just gives you all of the memory
that you that you're using here's an
example of how those get calculated this
game here has five pages three of them
are private just to the game and then
two of the pages in yellow here are
shared with other processes so if we
wanted to calculate PSS we would take
the private pages or three and then we
have one page is shared between two
processes so that's one half and then
one process that's shared I sorry one
page that's shared between two three
processes so that's one third then you
multiply at all times the page size and
that gives you a total amount of PSS now
RSS they said much simpler we have five
pages and then just multiply times the
page size now one of the new things
we've added in queue this is I think
really going to be useful for people who
want to trace memory or track their
memory is RSS trace points and I
mentioned RSS is much faster to collect
than PSS memory so you don't have these
delays and because you don't have these
delays you're not gonna miss those peaks
where the memory might reach a peak and
they go go down but you might miss it
because it takes so long to collect that
PSS information and it's great for this
new tool called
perfetto what is perfetto well if you
haven't heard of perfetto it's a new
tool that actually resides on the device
and it collects information on the
device it can do things like heap
profiling which also later and the
really really interesting thing I think
for games particularly is it can collect
arbitrarily long traces so this means
that you can run your game through an
entire level and be collecting all of
this trace information you can see all
your memory changes in with very high
detail over the entire length of that
session that you're collecting some of
the other things that can do it has
offline you can do offline processing
because it has an SQL query that you can
do on the data and you can collect an
information yourself and do your own
analysis of it also it has a new UI
similar to systrace called perfetto UI
so to enable it on your device in the
developer settings go to system tracing
and make sure you enable perfetto here
you also want to enable long traces and
also trace debuggable applications then
go to the categories section and make
sure memory is checked because if you're
collecting memory you want to make sure
that's checked then you just hit record
trace and it starts tracing and you'll
get this notification and when you're
done tracing just tap that notification
here's an example of perfetto UI for
tracing memory and you can see how it
collects this memory information about
anonymous memory and at various types of
RSS memory over time so you can see how
the memory is growing over time so now
that we have these tools to collect all
of this information I want you to
remember back when I talked about this
test app and why does it why is it able
to allocate 4.1 gigabytes so let's look
at it with perfetto if you look at the
memory over time and this is more
towards the end of the collect of the
allocations we can see how the anonymous
memory the the malloc memory starts to
flatten out that's the part on the top
here however
the swap memory continues to go up
now remember swap is stored in Z room
and Z room is compressed mam or memory
so all of this memory is compressed so
even though it says 4.2 gigabytes that
one point seven is all compressed memory
so it takes up less space so here's this
app running you can see as I'm tapping
here in the bottom the memory keeps
going up and I want you to notice here
as we get around to two gigabytes we get
our first entre memory warning it says
it's running low we keep allocating
memory and a three gigabytes it gets
critical I start to slow down on the
tapping to allocate slower and notice
now we can hit 4.1 gigabytes so it
really does work once again I don't
recommend allocating that much memory
more than likely you're gonna start
thrashing when you get to that much
memory so at the other tool I wanted to
mention here another tool is heap
property and this is also part of
perfetto
it's used for memory tracking memory
debugging finding memory leaks it's much
easier to use than malloc debug you
basically just run a script you don't
have to instrument your game so very
easy to use and the other nice feature
about it it has very low overhead so you
can run your game much faster doesn't
get slowed down like it does with malloc
debug here's an example of some output
from heap property if i zoom in here
hopefully you can see this every line
here is an allocation that hasn't been
freed yet and it shows the function
associated with that memory allocation
so you know if you see some memory here
that's been that's still allocated
that's not free where you expected it to
be free that would be an indication of a
memory leak another tool that's often
overlooked is bug report
now when I say bug report I don't mean
taking you know making or
and sending to us as a bug what I'm
talking about is the tool that's
collects log information it's similar to
look something like adb logcat only it's
much more detailed and then really good
thing about it is it shows low memory
killer activity the other nice thing
about it it can be captured after a
crash happens so you don't you don't
need to inter instrument your game and
you know expect when a crash is gonna
happen if a crash happens and you just
noticed it you then just take a bug
report so to capture a bug report you
once again going to the developer
options and you tap on this take bug
report and in a couple minutes this
notification will come up telling you
that a bug report has been captured and
you can tap on it and then share it with
yourself another way to do this is to
just call ad or just run a DB bug report
and you can get the information that way
here's an example of a bug report log
file and if we're looking for memory
killing we can search for this low
memory killer kill and in your package
name to see if your game was killed and
if you can see this there's a whole
bunch of low memory killer activity
going on here because we're running low
on memory and it's killing those
processes that aren't needed so it can
free up memory for your game so in this
instance yes the game the app was killed
by low memory killer so in case your
your game is crashing for some unknown
reason this will let you know it was
killed because it ran low on memory
so just to summarize here some things I
think are good to remember Android
unfortunately has no guarantees for the
amount of available memory that you have
the things to look out for are obviously
crashing that's the really bad one and
then also thrashing can happen and that
really is bad for performance I and I've
mentioned some of the new tools in queue
and hopefully you can use them to find
out what's going on and prevent these
bad things from happening in low memory
situations and finally you know I'm
hoping that now that you understand how
Android memory works you can put this to
use in your game also I want to remind
people that we're doing game reviews so
if you have a game you'd like us to
review you can go back here in the
garage section to have us look at your
game and that's it and I have some links
here in particular you might be
interested in the perfetto link it's
just
perfetto got dev pretty easy link here
and also in that perfetto documentation
is some description of he prof d so
that's it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]